the third tiebreaker game of the 2016
World Chess Championship took place
after having drawn both of the first two
games for those of you who've been
following my video series here on
YouTube you already know that game 1 was
a draw with Sergey Karjakin playing the
white pieces and then Magnus Carlsen
brought the house achieved a winning
advantage although once again failed to
convert against incredibly stubborn
defense against the Russian in game 2
and this my friends is what happened in
Game three after highlighting the fact
that it seems like no other conclusion
could possibly be drawn at this point
about Magnus Carlson's play than other
than he's just out of form not playing
well not converting on his opportunities
Sergey Karjakin on the other hand is
defending when he's down at finding all
of the only moves when he truly has to
find them and it seems like at some
point one of these sites is going to
have to give Carlsen is going to is
going to have to find a way to start
converting on advantages of surgery
cockin maybe gets a big win with white
and takes the world championship
certainly playing to black pieces after
blowing a winning advantage with white
could not be fun for the Norwegian as he
went into this game and once again
they've repeated the same opening that
they played not only in the first high
breaker game so you can back up and see
that video but also in game 11 of the
match and then also Game two of the
match so this position has been played
multiple times and finally for the first
time we actually see Carlsen say throw
away with my with my worries about
whether cardiac ins team has come up
with anything in the lab in their hotel
room I'm going back to what I did when I
first achieved a comfortable position as
black against this line with the move
Knight a5 and then Bishop to e6 this
position is exactly what we had on the
board in game 2 and in game 2 Sergey
Karjakin if you want to go see that
video of course it's on my personal
YouTube channel played the move d4 it
was noted in our analysis in that video
and all the chess center coverage we did
of Game two that the other move and the
position is the move b4 and this is the
that had been played by probably more
strong GM's before before this game but
with cardiac and playing d4 in game too
and on that note on that foreshadowing
note circa cardiac and actually played
the move b4 here rather than trying to
repeat what he did against Magnus
Carlsen and game two sort of interesting
that from my perspective if you were
looking for an improvement you would
think you would be repeating a little
bit more of what you did in game two
versus the world champion but apparently
not apparently he'd rather play into b4
which is the road more commonly traveled
and after Knight to c6 he immediately
plays Knight to d5 this is exactly the
kind of structure that we got in game 11
so though the move order is different
here this is exactly the kind of game
that we had there with both sides
putting their Knights on d4 it's going
to be a closed position so black is less
worried about losing the bishop error
and white has to make some big decisions
about the kind of center you want to
have in in games in game 11 we had a
position where the trade on d4 actually
occurred and at some point you saw black
using the queenside majority but not
here in this game
Carl Carl cardiac and excuse me
analyzing all these games Carlson and
cardiac can start the same way easy to
have a tongue-twister played the move
Knight to g5 which at first hand seems
interesting okay the Challenger was
ready for blood he just defended a lost
position as black and now he's white
looking to play an aggressive line but
what strangest is was the lack of
follow-up after 90 g5 which clearly aims
to dislodge the bishop Carlsen gives up
the bishop air and then immediately
retreats this night with a tempo which
not only serves to have an immediate
tactical threat but also to clear up the
potential of the F pawn driving home now
we all know that we should be attacking
in the direction of our pawn structure
always swim with the river not against
it and so it makes nothing but
positional sense that that Carlsen would
retreat this Knight and go for this line
which means if you played this line as
carrion you would have certainly had
something prepared for this approach by
black because it's one of them it's the
most logical positional idea that black
can execute in this in this position
but here rather than go back to f3 which
might be something that's a little bit
more passive it seems but it does avoid
the tempos Carlson gained call can
decide he was going to allow those
temples with 94 Carlson says I'll take
the opportunity and then f4 and suddenly
it became very very strange when you
realized that karaoke on once again
failed to show anything really at home
Carlson has spent all this time avoiding
night 85 going into the variation that
he played very early on the match for
all the strategy reasons we've talked
about avoiding any improvement by the
Russian team and so you would think that
there would be something in mind for y2
to repeat here or if not improving on an
earlier game if you're not going to
repeat then have something have
something well-prepared in the new
position but it didn't seem that that
was the case and suddenly Corey Aachen
is immediately on his toes with black
having a very strong night and the
threats on the kingside already being a
reality c3 is played which makes a lot
of sense you kick tonight back to f5 but
regardless of what the engine says above
me that's really there just for the
confirmation for those who just want to
make sure that when Danny says things
he's not totally full of it I respect
that and you want to make sure if I say
something the computer doesn't say Danny
you're saying black is winning and the
computer says white is up +5 most the
time the engine should be there is sort
of a guiding force kind of like a
Gandalf on your on your Frodo journey to
Mordor okay the computer should be seen
as a helpful hand guiding you but not
necessarily the ultimate determining
factor at least in terms of what plans
you're choosing what strategical ideas
you're trying to execute tactically yes
they are the gods they are the kings but
regardless of whether the computer still
believes the position is roughly equal I
look at this position it's just being so
much easier for black to play Black has
so many natural moves and the way the
players spent the next 10 15 moves told
me all I needed to know which was karak
and immediately felt he was on the
defensive side of things which means he
wasn't that well prepared for Carlsen to
repeat the thing he did in game 2 which
means the young above the cameras
opinion of cariocans approach in the
opening in this match seems
are more accurate that karaoke just
wanted to play a reuleaux PES which is
just a manoeuvring kind of game but
that's kind of right up Carlson's alley
so again just strange to see here and
and not trying to foreshadow the result
of the game at all because we're still
plenty to play but if I'm evaluating the
opening stage I'm just less than
impressed and I apologize for going so
quickly through the beginning part of
things but all those of you who have
been following all my videos on the
World Championship match on my youtube
channel and chess comm Channel I've
already talked about this very Lopez in
the opening stage so much really the
critical moments are happening now and
as I said so here comes the natural
moves Queen e8 could anything be more
natural bring more pieces to the Kings
side Queen to g6 that's that's exactly
what the doctor ordered a Bishop to b3
seems like a weird move but I don't
exactly see what the what the concrete
plan is for white in the position and
now f3 is played which if anything shows
nerves shows that white is worried about
blacks attack and it and it's a clear
concession right because you're playing
this move only because you must be
worried about tactical threats Knight h4
is coming which hits g2 and if the rook
is open will now f3 is a threat so
clearly white is worried about the
coming threats car y'all can actually
spend a decent amount of time on this
movement and played at three so again
it's just a tough position to be in as
white to have to start making conceding
moves like that
that are giving up so much control over
the dark squares the bishop pair is a
total non factor in this game I don't
want to make it seem like cardiac I
never had any improvements probably if
I'm going to suggest what it would be
here and I would be looking if I was
white to play moves like a 4 or c4 I
don't even care about the d4 score I'd
be looking to do anything to create
active counter play despite you know
what the computer says there anything
white has to look to open the position
for the bishops you have to look for
counter play that didn't happen and once
f3 is played you know black is the one
in the driver's seat
here comes Bishop h4 a4 is played the
knight comes in to f6 again Carlsen's
goals are very simple I'm going to bring
everything over to the Kings side and
see what happens Corey Aachen now plays
the move a4 which is the logical thing
we would expect white to do to use the
Queen side and try to open up some
things for the bishop but the real
problem is that the forcing sequence
that now occurs after Knight f6
white is worried
about things on e4 so the Queen comes to
eat you to defend a5 is the first move
that really shows that Carlsen is not
going to be content and he's not beating
himself up or worried about not
converting on a win in the last game
with the two bishops for the rook he's
looking to win again and I think he
recognized that he was better so for the
opening to go so quickly into blacks
favor is really a shock and he wants to
create avenues of entry on both sides of
the board right that's a sign of him
feeling confident that the pressure here
is practical against the king which is
just always makes your opponent nervous
and that he has the ability to be that
aggressive right he's ready to open
things up let's mix it up takes takes
and now Bishop to d2 cockiness is
looking to sacrifice that pawn in order
to complete development which makes
sense the only real problem with it is
that the bishop in order to guard d4 it
gives up III if the bishop comes back to
e3 d4 is falling so the potential of
these dark squares becoming a real issue
is already sort of looming out there and
the pawn structure itself is is the
King's Indian really forget the fact
that this came from a Spanish a Spanish
no Dani in Spanish forget the fact that
it came from a Lopez a Spanish game the
pawn structure here is one that you
would seem normally in a Kings Indian
with the one exception that black didn't
being kettle the Bishop blackouts an
attack and what white needs against the
Kings Indian structure is always
pressure against the base if you're
playing the white side of these
positions where white is trying to
attack on the Queen side to compensate
for blacks pressure white needs to have
pressure against c7 ASAP because when c7
falls the six might fall and if these
six might fall z5 might fall and you do
the math on where we're headed with that
White's goals have to be aggressive
there and unfortunately for what it
feels like he's just a day late and a
dollar short in terms of that necessary
plan here comes the night into e3 and
after Brooke - c1 trades on a1 just to
make sure there's not going to be any
pressure coming to c7 the Queen -
relocates but not because she's
necessarily conceding there's there's
issues with whites Queen side right now
currently there's a weak b5 pawn I've
run up against a little bit of a lack of
a lack of concrete moves I guess on the
on the King side so so this move makes
sense but after Bishop to c4 King h8
karyakin
starts to lose his cool a little bit
himself and doesn't quite know now how
to sit on the position King AJ threatens
something that's going to bring us into
the fool Kings Indian transposition that
is to play a move like g5 why is it a
move like g5 really possible before well
among other things I think with the king
being on this diagonal there may be some
potential threats
sometimes there's ideas where you sack
the b6 pawn to open a pressure against
the d6 pawn so I think King h8 is a is a
very useful prophylactic move prepares
for g5 to be that much stronger when you
do play it without counter play and in
some cases maybe even opens up the g8
square for the Brooks Oh King h8 makes
sense and Karl's Carl Carr yakun I
really need to slow down a little bit
don't I everybody Carr yakin decides he
doesn't want to just sit on the position
and trades on f6 he did so with the idea
that maybe he could sit tight here with
less minor pieces for black maybe
there's less chances that I get
checkmated at least that's what he's
telling himself but unfortunately this
this approach of trading on f6 to avoid
the advancing of the Jeep on trying to
take some minors off the board backfires
very quickly for Kuryakin and since the
engine still doesn't see the move even
for those of you who would rely on the
engine I'll give you a chance to think
here on what the most somatic approaches
for black and it's a very it's the kind
of move that had the chat going wild as
I was watching the game live because the
computer evaluation initially goes nuts
but all the strong players were like wow
what of what a phenomenal approach to
the position what a fantastic idea and
it's very xeric 1915 3s by David
Bronstein if you haven't read Zurich
1953 by David Bronstein you're missing
out talking about what matters and chefs
is square control the ability to create
threats but the value and activity and
placement of your piece is far more
important than the number of them that
you have that doesn't mean you can win
if you're down ten pieces okay but the
the ability to control a certain area of
the board and the ability to really
restrict your opponent via one Avenue if
you over dominate a color complex we've
already been talking about the fact that
black on the dark square
usually that gives you access to other
areas of the board because you've
strangled your opponents so hard on one
area it's like the the tip we give that
an obstacle Bishop attacking positions
they can favor the is the person who's
attacking because the other Bishop just
sort of feels like a bystander if you're
attacking on the dark square if the
light square bishop feels useless and
vice versa if you're attacking on the
light squares so all those tips coming
coming into your mind looking to control
the board via the dominance of your dark
squares if you're black looking to
looking to increase your concrete access
to those squares despite whether you
have to give up some material or not and
strategically making sure that you can
control and create threats making sure
that's the more important thought in
your mind rather than the small amount
of material you have all those things
should lead you to having sound
Carlson's brilliant move and that is the
movie Forex clam
forget about what the computer says
after takes takes we shake and bake the
Queen comes in to e5 not only is black
going to dominate because control over
the dark squares and immediate tactical
threats but the a file
combined with the pressure that the
Queen holds on the a1 square means that
white is white is already begging for
life the position is falling apart their
threats like Queen to d4 followed by the
rook infiltrating and white has no
pressure as I said White's a day late
and a dollar short for any kind of
concrete counter play on the C file and
you'll notice the evaluation already is
like slowly turning black toward it back
toward at first white was so happy to be
up a pawn but now Corey Aachen
recognized what was happening here he
gets himself in big trouble h3 h6 slow
moves are played because karyakin really
can't prevent what's coming the Queen
enters into d4 and after the Queen goes
to e1 here comes more concrete frets
queen-to-be to Bishop f1 rook to a2
hitting the g2 Square this is a
nightmare nightmare nightmare and a half
probably the last chance of white has
here is to try to play tickle something
like rook to b1 if black plays tickle
then you know we keep we keep tickling
because we're losing but once the Queen
comes back either a 5 or f6 the threat
of Queen g5 is just winning so white has
to play h4 and and really the position
is just
it's one that white can't hold because
it's only a matter of time before
something concrete happens with the g2
pond falling here the threats against
the king I mean I don't even I didn't
even come up in my preparation with a
winning plan to prove that the black
would have still been winning had Carl
cannot wonder but I'm sure there's a
number of them including advancing the
cheap on making moves like rook to d2
just to make sure the Queen is
completely strangled and then tactics
with Knight to see to seem to actually
trap the clean so there's just there's
just an the fact of the computer now
realizes black is winning despite the
fact that black is down upon should tell
you how tough this position was for
cardiac on and so on that note he took
on c7 rather than playing tickle and
immediately resigned after the move rook
a1 which is just a skewer of the Queen
to the bishop winning a piece for
nothing and followed by mate really so
there you go the the table is completely
turned in this match with Magnus Carlsen
winning the third tiebreaker game is
black I guess to highlight any more
defensive opportunities maybe here
instead of king h2 the computer has been
saying this move Queen 82 for a while
but again it's just it's so hard to say
that sitting tight is any kind of
solution yeah I love rook a 1 you can't
trade by the way because then I take
with check and then win your Bishop
white is hanging by a thread and that's
and that might be the the most PG way to
describe what's going on with white
right now it's just it's just a
completely bogus position dominance of
the dark squares complete control over
the only critical areas and white being
way too way way too behind in terms of
the necessary counter play to be able to
play this game so a huge win for Magnus
Carlsen coming in Game three of the tie
breakers and just to show you again
instant replay of what happened there
was moving into Game four the World
Championship is on the line with a one
game lead and the rapid Tiber eight all
Magnus Carlsen needs now is a draw with
white but the Challenger has proven
himself worthy to this point we're going
to see what happens right now make sure
you click to the next video and watch
Game four